here's what would happen if you drank  toilet water  the water that fills your toilet bowl  when you flush is the same water that  comes from your tap but once it starts  mixing in your toilet bowl with cleaning  chemicals and the 10 trillion bacteria  in an average person's poop it's a less  than delicious combo now if it were  desperate times should you drink it  probably not flushing doesn't eliminate  all germs if you absolutely have to make  sure you boil it first otherwise you'll  be facing some serious stomach cramping  and  diarrhea you might even come down with a  fever or blood poisoning you know in  2025 66 of us worldwide will likely face  water shortages so why not get a head  start on this unique fresh water source  countries like singapore and australia  already drink recycled waste water it  can be cleaned so well that it's used in  industrial processes requiring pure  water so